[Music]
welcome to another episode of code this
not that where we tried to write the
best code possible and avoid the bad
stuff today we're going to look at
intersection observer and how to
determine the visibility of elements in
the Dom this is a very useful tool
because you can use it for things like
infinite scroll lazy loaded images and
animations in today's video we'll look
at two different ways we can build out
this lazy loaded image feature using
nothing but vanilla JavaScript if you're
new here like and subscribe and grab the
source code from fire ship IO and I'll
be giving away the first ever fire ship
IOT shirt all you have to do is leave a
comment below and we'll pick a random
winner next week intersection observer
is a browser API that we can use to
observe the visibility of an element in
the viewport it's currently supported by
most browsers with the main exception
being Safari but there is a polyfill
that you can use as needed I actually
use it on fire ship IO to lazy load the
comments section the comments live in
fire store so this prevents unnecessary
reads to the database and another thing
you might notice on fire ship is that
page transitions are super fast this is
made possible in part by a library
called quick link which uses
intersection observer to preload all the
links that are visible on the page so
there's all kinds of cool use cases but
let's go ahead and get started by
writing some bad code what we have here
is just a basic HTML page and we have
some high resolution images on it that
we want to lazy load so when the user
Scrolls to an image it will load it and
then do this little CSS animation the
CSS itself is pretty straightforward
we start with an opacity of zero and a
transform and then we fade in by adding
this fade class which sets the opacity
to 1 then in the HTML we'll go ahead and
reference a script called app J s and
that'll be a deferred script and you'll
notice with the images in this page that
instead of having a source attribute
they have a data lazy attribute this is
our own custom attribute that we can use
to point to the image itself and then
we'll use our JavaScript to set it as
the actual image source when it becomes
visible in the viewport the first thing
we'll do is grab all of the images in
the Dom by using query selector all then
we'll listen to the scroll event on the
window and every time the user Scrolls
we'll be able to recalculate whether or
not an element is visible after that we
can loop over each image and run the
calculation the calculation is
determined by the get bounding client
rect value so we'll be looking at the
top of the element if the top of the
element is less than or equal to the
window inner height
and we know that it's visible from there
we'll go ahead and read that data lazy
attribute so we know that a true source
of the image and once we have that value
we'll just go ahead and call set
attributes for the source and we'll also
go ahead and add that fade class to run
the animation so that codes actually
very simple and it works but it's also
very inefficient and will very likely
cause performance issues if we go back
to the demo you can see that I'm console
pooping every time that calculation runs
by the time we get to the bottom of the
page we've already taken over 3000
console poops and not only that but the
event listener is still running even
after all the images load so it's doing
all the calculations for no reason in
the background on the main thread let's
see how we can use intersection observer
to clean up this mess we'll start with
the function called lazy load that takes
a Dom element as its argument then we'll
create an intersection observer for each
image that we want to lazy load it has a
callback function that has the entries
which are the actual observations on the
element and then observer is the
interface that we can use to manage the
actual instance of this observer by
default it will listen to the top level
viewport on the document but you can
pass in an options object if you want to
listen to a specific div or element at
this point I want to make a note that
you can use a single intersection
observer to listen to multiple images
but in this demo I'm going to give each
image its own observer and I'll show you
why in just a minute the next step is to
loop over the entries and see if any of
them are intersecting with the viewport
and fortunately we don't have to do any
of our own calculation we can just call
entry is intersecting which will turn a
boolean true or false
however there are situations where you
probably want to do some calculations
here so you have access to all of the
bounding boxes for the elements from
here we need to get the actual image
that has intersected with the window
which we can do by coin entry target and
then we can run the same logic that we
did in the previous example that adds
the attribute and the fade class now at
this point we know the image is visible
so we can dispose of the observer by
calling observer disconnect that means
we won't have any unnecessary work
happening on the main thread like we did
in the previous example and it's also
why I set up an observer for each image
the last thing we need to do in this
function is call observe on the target
element and then finally we'll loop over
all of the elements in the DOM and apply
this observer to them when we reload the
page we get seven console logs initially
which are for these seven images on the
page then as we scroll down we'll start
to intersect with the images and trigger
additional console logs
in total our code only runs 13 times
which is much better than the 4000 poops
we took a few minutes ago I'm gonna go
ahead and wrap things up there if this
video helped you please like and
subscribe thanks for watching and I will
talk to you soon
[Music]